este informe como decíamos reseña lo
ocurrido en el año 2022 Cuáles fueron
los factores principales que
contribuyeron a este aumento en el
número de refugiados Y desplazados a lo
largo del mundo
Gracias Santiago nuevamente por la
invitación un gusto estar acá como vos
mencionabas el reporte que lanzó el
acnur
digamos recolecta todas las estadísticas
del año 2022 en el año 2022 fueron
108,4 millones de personas que han sido
desplazadas por la fuerza y en
comparación a lo que vos decías recién
hablaban de números que que van en
aumento durante el veinte veintitrés si
consideramos la situación que está
atravesando Sudán estas cifra se eleva
aún más a ciento a ciento diez coma
cuatro millones de personas desplazadas
por la fuerza estas cifras en
comparación de lo que fue el 2021
estamos hablando de un 21% de aumento de
personas que se encuentran desplazadas
por la fuerza y entre ellas hay 35,3
millones de personas refugiadas y otras
62,5 personas millones de personas
disculpas que están desplazadas una
fuerza internamente no que se encuentran
dentro de su país las principales
razones tienen que ver con vos decías
recién hablábamos de la guerra en una
nota anterior las situaciones de
conflicto en la guerra son las causas
principales de hecho aún Siria sigue
siendo el país que mayor cantidad de
personas refugiadas hay en el mundo con
seis coma cinco lo mismo que Ucrania con
cinco coma siete en tanto estas causas
estructurales sumadas a otras como los
efectos del cambio climático no se
puedan resolver Lamentablemente siempre
en esta época del año tenemos que a esta
triste y lamentable noticia de que
siempre emitimos récords no de las
cifras comparadas a los años anteriores
hablando de cifras en realidad las
previsiones indican que el
desplazamiento no va a disminuir en este
2023 por qué lo consideran así
bueno efectivamente como te comentaba el
reporte abarca hasta el año 2022 sin
embargo si analizamos hasta mayo de este
año particularmente por la situación en
Sudán ya vemos que las cifras van en
aumento y Lamentablemente las causas
estructurales que están causando
los desplazamientos forzados en el corto
plazo no vemos que se vayan a resolver
En ese sentido es muy importante tener
en cuenta poder tener un análisis
estructural
integral y panorámico no de de la
situación no solamente es como las
causas que están generando este
desplazamiento forzado como Las Guerras
los conflictos de aviones las
violaciones de Derechos Humanos sino
también es importante entender que los
países necesitan desarrollarse necesitan
encontrar soluciones dentro de sus
propios países para que estas personas
no tomen la triste decisión de irse no
de su propio país sí vemos también que
son los países del sur global no los que
lideran los datos de acogida están
preparadas estas naciones para recibir a
los miles que usen en busca de
protección
en 76% de los países que reciben a las
personas desplazadas por las fuerzas son
países de renta baja y media y te vuelvo
a repetir esta idea que me parece muy
importante un país solo no va a poder
afrontar o resolver esta situación
estamos hablando de millones de personas
millones de historias que podríamos
haber sido vos o yo
no no es un una situación que pueda
resolver un solo país en ese sentido es
muy importante que sea una
responsabilidad compartida entre toda la
comunidad internacional que afronta esta
situación tomando en cuenta las razones
por las cuales las personas se van de
esos países pero también Cuáles son las
situaciones humanitarias que tenemos que
abordar
durante el tránsito no de estas personas
que se movilizan y también en los países
a los que llega